thank you everyone can you uh can you
hear me okay here
yep
very good morning thank you for your
flexibility with a slight change in
timing for this uh this press conference
my name is Peter Lawson and I'm an
assistant chief Constable here with like
constabulary
I'm joined to my left by detective
superintendent Becky Smith
Becky's the senior investigating officer
sio in the investigation to find Nicola
bully
I want to thank you for making the
effort to come here this morning so we
could give you an update
on our investigation to find Nicola
um
she and her family remain foremost in
our thoughts and our priorities in the
investigation
some of what Becky and I will say today
has already been made public and has
been widely reported
but I'm acutely aware that it continues
to be extensive media interest
commentary speculation and indeed some
criticism of our police investigation
therefore to try and address some of
that we will take you through in some
detail
more than would normally be the case
with an investigation
what exactly we've done over the last 19
days and continued to do
to remind us Nicola went missing on the
morning of Friday the 27th of January
and since that time we have done an
unprecedented amount of work on the
investigation to try and find her
the sole focus of that work is to find
liquor
to bring it home to a family and give
them the answers they so desperately
need
the investigations involved a dedicated
team of more than 40 detectives
they've been looking through hundreds of
hours of CCTV dash cam footage
speaking to numerous Witnesses
carrying out digital inquiries and
examining literally hundreds of pieces
of information submitted by the public
and I would like to thank the public for
all of their assistance throughout this
investigation
there are also dozens of other officers
and staff who have helped in the
investigation
searches
and reassurance of a local community in
St Michaels
we've involved a range of Specialists
both locally regionally and nationally
the investigation has not wanted at any
stage for experts who are the best in
their field available to law enforcement
in the UK
I would emphasize that it Remains the
case there is no evidence
to indicate a criminal aspect or
third-party involvement in Nicholas
disappearance
however the the officers involved in the
investigation
are the same experienced Specialists and
many senior officers
who are concerned with the investigation
of the most serious and complex crimes
that is the importance and focus we have
given to the investigation to find
Nicola
to give you some figures to back up some
of what I've described
we visited more than 300 premises
spoke into almost 300 people and
received around about 1 500 pieces of
information into the inquiry
in terms of the physical searches both
water-based and on land
we've used specialist resources from
both police
a range of other agencies but I'm
grateful to those other agencies who've
supported us
and in police assets that's included the
Northwest underwater search unit
police drones horses dogs and the police
helicopter
we continue to search extensively the
river wire
and surrounding area Downstream and out
into the sea towards the estuary
we've consulted with national experts in
their field including environmental
Untitled experts
and we're carrying out next to have
carried out an extensive land search
uh surrounding the river including some
properties around the area where Nicola
went missing
slides have been made available for you
to to see which show in some detail
exactly where we were searched but it's
impossible it's important to say that
our activity because at every stage been
directed by expert trained police search
advisors who return pulses
and they've been following nationally
recognized Doctrine around search
strategy which will be followed by any
expert police search advisor in UK
policing
the lead police search advisor is here
and at the conclusion of the press
conference if you have any specific
questions on a one-to-one basis with
that officer they will be able to assist
with those
so it Remains the case at the present
time that there is no evidence in all
the exhaustive inquiries we've made and
suggests any crime has been committed
or that there is any third-party
involvement in Nicholas disappearance
it is important for me to stress that
the investigation continues it is
ongoing
and we are meticulously reviewing all
information gathered from Nicholas
gathered from members of Nicholas family
the public
CCTV
dash cam and other digital devices to
name just a few
we're also continuing to regularly
consult with national experts from the
National Crime agency the MCA
and they continue to support us and
provide both tactical and strategic
advice
for the case
I will now hand over to to Becky who
will talk through in some more detail
the investigation has been she's been
leading from that senior investigating
officer role
thank you thank you for coming this
morning
so I'm going to firstly take you through
the incident that led up to Nicola being
reported missing I'll go through a
timeline of events for you followed by a
number of topic areas that I believe are
of interest to you
also going on to a couple of areas that
have been highlighted in the Press which
I want to explain in detail
so first of all Nicola bully was
reported missing on Friday the 27th of
January after dropping her children at
St Michael's School instant Michaels
as soon as she was reported missing
following the information that was
provided to the police by her partner
Paul
and based on a number of specific
vulnerabilities that we were made aware
of Nicola was graded as high risk
that is normal in a missing person from
investigation with the information we
were in possession of
she was immediately treated as a misper
and then on the Monday the 30th of
January I was identified as a series as
the senior investigating officer
at that time we reviewed all the
information that had been gathered in
the days prior to her being reported
and as any senior investigating officer
does you form a number of hypotheses
that is scenarios which are possible
from the information to hand
those hypotheses included the one that
she possibly could have gone into the
river
that there could have been third party
involvement and lastly that she could
have left the area voluntarily
those hypotheses have remained in place
throughout are reviewed regularly as is
normal with any sio running a major
investigation
at the initial stages based on the
information I received
I made it clear that it was my working
hypothesis at that time based with all
the facts
that the main hypothesis I was working
on at that time was that Nicola had gone
in the river
this has been misconstrued in the Press
and said that that was what I said
I said that was my main working
hypothesis at that time and that remains
my main working hypothesis I think it's
clear to see that the amount of effort
hours worked resources that we've put
into this investigation that we have
always been open-minded those three
hypotheses and scenarios have been
continually reviewed and continue to do
so to this day
but as Mr Dawson has said at the minute
with the information that we have
received and reviewed there is not a
single piece of information or evidence
to suggest that there is any third-party
involvement in this investigation
and that continues and will continue to
do so until we have reviewed all the
information received
so in terms of the actual timeline
Nicola bully dropped her children off at
school at about 8 40 on Friday the 27th
of January
that was normal and she then proceeded
after chatting to a couple of people in
the school yard walked up garstang Road
and onto the river path uh overnight
bridge that takes you down to these
fields
we know that because there are witnesses
who have identified her and also from
her phone data
we know that Nicola entered the field
and
um
made a couple of messages on her mobile
phone
one to her boss and one to a friend
making arrangements for a play date for
her children
and at 901
we know she logged into a work call on
teams
again there's been lots of speculation
about this this was a perfectly normal
call for Nicola to have it was work
related she would never have had the
microphone or camera on because it was
more of an informative session she
didn't need to sign into it she did so
to enable her with her business
so I know there have been inquiries as
to whether anybody else on the team's
call would have been able to hear or
provide us with any information I could
assure you from the outset that was
investigated thoroughly and that is not
the case
we know at this time that there were a
number of dog walkers
in the area and we've been extremely
fortunate from the very start of this
inquiry to have a number of witnesses
key Witnesses who know Nicola so there
is no miscommunication about the
identification of who was in that field
and also we've viewed a substantial
amount of CCTV again whilst we can't
cover the whole area with CCTV we've
been really fortunate and that we've had
a lot which has really been able to help
us in pin down both Nicholas movements
and also the movements of key Witnesses
which is why we were able to give a
timeline of events quite quickly but
reiterating that we were remaining
open-minded to all three of those
scenarios
so Nicola was last seen in the field
which we've called the upper field at
about 9 10 that morning
at that time everything seemed normal
she was walking her dog Willow who was
off the lead and again a number of
issues and inconsistencies have been
raised in relation to Willow and her
harness
it was really normal for Willow not to
have her harness on they never kept the
harness on when they were in that field
the harness would be taken off Willow
when they entered the field and would
only be put back on when they were ready
to leave the field
so at approximately 9 10
a witness that knows her
um had the last sighting and that was at
the upper field when I say an
approximate time it is that but we are
basing that on obviously the times that
we can say that witness left the field
so I'm quite confident it is around that
time
we then know from Digital Data that at
some time around 9 20 we believe that
Nicholas handset had moved to towards
the bench area
again there have been questions raised
about her phone whether that would have
been in a possession when whatever
happened has happened but again I'd just
like to point her out that it's really
normal for Nicola when in a team's call
to be holding her phone out in front of
her listening to it and we can say from
a witness that knows her that morning
that is what she was doing so that would
explain why she doesn't have her phone
in her pocket as I know a number of
people have raised
we then know at about 9 33 a local dog
walker who is walking a dog comes across
the bench and finds Willow
um untied running between the bench and
the gate
the mobile phone is on the bench face
upwards still logged into the team's
call and Willow's harness is halfway
between the bench and the Riverside
that witness makes a number
um before returning home she she then
returns and makes a number of phone
calls to people because at that point
she doesn't know who the dog belongs to
or who the phone belongs to and doesn't
know how to get in touch with people
she makes a number of inquiries with a
local vet who can't assist her and
following a number of inquiries
eventually
people return to the bench recover the
handset and Willow and we find out that
obviously they belong to Nicola
the alarm is then raised with the local
school who then in turn contact Paul
Nicholas partner who then makes to the
scene
just moving on to CCTV
like I've said we've got we are really
fortunate in this inquiry that we've
been able to narrow down a lot of the
Witnesses in the area's movements and to
some extent Nicholas
but we can't complete that totally
the area at the top of the field Rowan
water
have CCTV that covers the gate
enters the field and the front of the
site
that is working the site managers have
been cooperating with us
I'm so supportive of this investigation
at every stage and we can say that
Nicola has not entered that area
or left
we can also say that nobody that we
haven't traced and spoken to and
discounted has left or entered Rome
Water
second point on CCTV is allotment Lane
again we've been really really fortunate
despite it being such a rural area that
we've got numerous sites of CCTV on that
road and that is why we can be confident
that Nicola has not gone down that road
unfortunately the main entrance and exit
to the fields is by the river path as we
refer to it and that River path goes
back to garstan Road
you can Fork off slightly which takes
you at the back of the grapes Pub which
would bring you back onto the main road
but again that is covered by CCTV and we
know she hasn't left by that entrance
so talking about the river path this has
always been and we've made this really
clear in previous briefings and
bulletins that this has been our Focus
and to do this because of the lack of
CCTV on the main road we've had to
appeal numerous times for motorists and
cyclists in the area to send us through
any potential clips of dash cam
and Our intention is to review every one
of those however small they might be
to make sure that I'm none of those
nickel received
at this stage nobody none of that dash
cam has indicated that Nicola is there
however I'd just like to point out we
are still reviewing those pieces of
information
what I can say
which we've established only yesterday
was that the if Nicola had left out of
the river path and turned right she has
not reached the great Pub
and we can say that because we have CCTV
covering both sides of that pavement
so moving on to Nicholas phone
I've talked to you about the
discrepancies that have been flagged up
with the teams call whether she would
have had that in front of her whether
she would have happened in a pocket and
we can say with confidence that Nicola
that morning whilst logged into her
team's call had the phone out in front
of her listening to that call
we have of course like you would in any
major inquiry
done an exhaustive amount of work with
that phone we have digital media experts
doing everything we can with that and
that has enabled us to help us with her
movements in the field corroborated by
the witness accounts
moving on to Fitbit as I know this is
It's been of Interest unfortunately
despite many technicians and Specialists
looking at this there is no further
information that we can gain from that
because it hadn't been synced for a
number of days
just in relation to digital digital
inquiries there is further work that we
are doing on Nicholas social media
accounts this morning
the family are totally aware of this
but these uh this work that we're doing
might show Nicola as being online
I want to make this really clear we have
controlled this phone this will be the
police
that is doing these inquiries and that
nobody needs to be concerned or to
contact the incident room in relation to
this
moving back to my original uh
explanation of the scenarios that were
under consideration
I've expressed before the hypotheses
have been continually reviewed based on
the information that is known to the
inquiry team and the inquiry team only
whilst other people may speculate and
spread rumors there is no evidence
whatsoever or information and there has
been a vast amount reviewed I can assure
you in the last almost three weeks to
suggest any third-party involvement or
Nicola leaving that field
however this is an ongoing inquiry we've
got a large dedicated team
and as you can imagine vast amount of
information some relevant and some not
coming in on a daily basis so whilst my
main working line of inquiry at the
moment is that Nicola based on the
information known to me from the
incident and of Nicola herself and the
information and vulnerabilities that
have been given to us by her family
that is my main working hypothesis at
this time that does not mean that we
aren't continuing to investigate every
single line of inquiry because I can
assure you we are and we as much as
everybody else in this country wants to
find out what's happened to Nicola to be
able to give her two children the
answers they deserve
so in terms of persistent myths that
keep being referred to in the Press
um the derelict house which is across
the other side of the river
that has been searched three times with
the permission of the owner and Nicola
is not in there
the red van
we're really really grateful to members
of the public for ringing into the
inquiry we wouldn't have got this far
without everybody's help
but I think it's also really obvious
that we are being inundated with false
information
accusations and rumors which is
distracting us from our work
the red van
um has been reported that it was in the
area on the morning of the 27th like
many other hundreds of cars that morning
we're really grateful for the witness
who has told us about that and we are
continuing to make inquiries to try and
track down that specific van but from my
perspective being in possession of all
the facts and information of this case I
do not believe that to be suspicious but
we are continuing to investigate that so
that we can identify whoever was in the
area that time to make sure that they
can't give us any further information
that will assist the investigation
there's also been mentioned of a number
of fishermen that have been seen that
morning who again were described as
suspicious
and myself don't find it suspicious that
fishermen would be in the area of a
river that morning or carrying fishing
rods but there was some suggestion that
one of these males might have been
looking to cover his face
we have made numerous appeals for these
fishermen to come forward we have made
contact with the local angling clubs and
we have also ascertained the time of the
witness passing down that road and
checked the CCTV at the grapes Pub which
covers that end of garstang Road and we
can't see any of those fishermen at that
time on that day but we are continuing
to try and Trace these people again I
would urge that they are not necessarily
suspicious to me
but I'm really Keen to trace them to
make sure that there's no further
information that they can give us that
will assist
in terms of the glove that has been
recovered you'll no doubt be aware that
tick tockers have been um playing their
own private detectives and have been in
the area
a glove has been recovered that is not
believed to be relevant to the
investigation it is not Nicholas but we
have got that in our possession
lastly there has been some mention of
CCTV specifically at the Caravan site
that hasn't been working and that that
suspicious itself that is not the case
we have been helped and assisted beyond
all belief by the Caravan owners in this
the whole Community wants to find Nicola
and wants to give the family the answers
that they deserve
lastly the family and they are the most
important part of this and all this
speculation and rumor is affecting them
they've got a loving daughter sister
partner and mother who is missing and
that is my priority and the priority of
the investigation team and always has
and we can't be detracted from that
I have met the family
on a number of occasions and will
continue to do so and they are kept
through regularly updated throughout
with our progress
there are dedicated family liaison
officers who speak daily to the family
and Only Yesterday spent a significant
amount of time with Paul
I could assure you that this
investigation has been thoroughly
investigated no differently than any
other major investigation from the
outset and that my absolute priority is
to do everything we can to provide the
answers to Nicola's two daughters who
need to know where their mummy is
and whilst we have shared information
today about specific individual
vulnerabilities
specific to this case a Nicola I would
ask you to respect the family's privacy
in respect of those things
thank you
thank you Becky um
as I mentioned we we've shared more
detail in this conference than would
normally be the case but in terms of by
doing so both in terms of the the scale
of the investigation the resources and
the intensity of it
and something around Nicholas
vulnerabilities that we're able to
counter some of the and I won't be clear
but it'll inform speculation and
conjecture that has at times destructed
the investigation from what ought to
have been its priorities it has been a
distraction
now there's potentially damaging to the
investigation the community of Saint
Michael's
um most importantly Nicholas family
however we've had incredible support
from the public
and continue to have a dedicated
investigation team working on this
inquiry and we will continue to be as
transparent as we possibly can be
uh you must appreciate though that when
we do come forward what we bring forward
must be factual tooth
anybody with relevance information can
submit it through the the major incident
public portal the MIP the link to which
is available or the Lancashire Police
website
so thank you and both Becky and I are
happy to take some questions guys
um
how that detective superintendent um
can you just give us a bit more
information about what Nikki's partner
told you about her vulnerabilities and
why was it that you had to then identify
her as high risk and also
this is the 20th day that Nicola bully
has been missing how confident are you
and your team that you will find her
alive
okay so firstly to cover the information
about Paul
it's normal in any missing person
investigation that you obviously gather
as much information at an early stage
about the person in question which is no
different and we did that with Paul
I'm not going to go into the details of
those individual vulnerabilities I've
asked you to respect the family who are
going through unimaginable pain and
distress at this moment
but those vulnerabilities based are
decision making in terms of grading
Nicola as high risk and have continued
to form part of my investigation
throughout
in terms of sorry what was the second
part of your question it's the 20th day
since Nicola has been missing how
confident are you and your team that
you'll find Nicola bully alive
hope with all my heart that we find
Nicola bully alive more than anything
how confident are you
I I've told you that my working
hypothesis is at the moment through all
the information that we have gathered
that the likelihood is that Nicola
has unfortunately gone in the river
however I have to stress this because
this has been continually misconstrued
I cannot be 100 certain of that at the
minute because we are continuing it's a
live investigation and there is always
information coming in but we are in the
20th day we have had a thorough
dedicated meticulous investigation and
there is not one single piece of
information that's come to know that
would suggest that Nicola has left those
fields thank you
first of all
come to the end onto the Iron Bridge
turn left so right yes yes
are we saying that to the left is a
blind spot and if so how far down
there's no CCTV there I think not on
that main I can't give you the specifics
of the exactly how many states but we
were basically scoping off all the as
you turn left we're trawling all that
area for any CCTV that we have got but
the main road that area there isn't
covered unfortunately so from the Iron
Bridge so from the Iron Bridge to the
school if you will
there is nothing there which is why it's
so important for the dash cam because
even though they're going to be tiny
Bitesize of information they're not
going to be as good as being able to
view CCTV we need to be able to piece
together as much of that portion of the
road as we can 700 cars how many have
been spoken to or what percentage I
can't do the exact figures on that
because obviously there would have been
more today that have come in but a
substantial amount
no no they've all had individual letters
to the cars that we know have gone past
in the area not that particular but in
the area and we've asked for positive
responses only and any dash cam that's
come back in which there has been an
amount of we have reviewed some of it
doesn't show anything some is still
being reviewed but at the minute there
is absolutely no sightings of nickel on
there Danny BBC I'm starhubal records
when you reported sio on the Monday I
was yes
I I can probably take this I I am
satisfied that as as Becky has described
uh following the initial reports of
Nicola has been missing intellectual
police immediately she was graded as
high risk but that in itself is a
significant level of risk that doesn't
bring with its uh focused attention and
significant resources so I'm satisfied
that um given there was no evidence of
any crime having occurred at that first
point of the report yes it was handled
appropriately but as as the days began
to progress
um as would be normal with any High
dismissing person investigation uh who
hadn't turned up had hadn't been found
by one day we began to layer in the
expertise of a senior investigating
officer with all the the investigation
infrastructure that comes with that
Jamie Williamson from Power Media it
took a piece of folding and SGI three
days to determine if he wasn't in that
stretch of river how long will it take
lunch please and how long will you
continue searching The River Why until
you come to the same determination
and again it's probably something I can
take we um the search efforts both
water-based and land-based continues
this week there are police assets
including underwater search officers
continuing that exercise this week
water is an inherently challenging
medium to search and the river wire is
tidal and flows out into into the
Estuary near cochrom Sands and parts of
the river have been searched repeatedly
because of the shifting water patterns
and tidal nature of it we've taken the
best expertise from from people who are
experts in the field around Coastal
movements of water and movements of
water on inland waterways I retain all
hope but the reality is there will be a
point at which I need to review in
conjunction with Beck is the sio
um the search managers the extensive
proportionality of continuing to deploy
significant search resources around the
river wire and on the land-based options
we have there so for this week the
search effort is continuing there will
be a point in the days ahead where I do
need to review that
um they gone on BBC um social media
video makers and want to be detectives
so they've been an annoyance or a
hindrance in the inquiry take that if
you want
yes it has significantly distracted the
investigation
um
I had in 29 years Police Service I've
never seen anything like it some of it's
been quite shocking and really hurtful
to the family
obviously we can't disregard anything
and we've reviewed everything that's
coming but of course it has distracted
us significantly but as long as we are
prioritizing which we do constantly
on the information that's coming in that
will not distract us from the priority
actions that we have been completing
should you record which I've got friends
that you that you allow things like file
play and be absolutely
yeah I understand why you would ask that
but at the end of the day it was treated
as a high risk missing from home
immediately and the officers that dealt
with it in those days had the land
searched immediately which included the
area around the bench
is it not significant that Willow was
running between the bench and the gate
not the bench and the water's edge I
mean I don't expect to be an expert on
dog behavior and I'm not either but what
what do you make of that what is anyone
what what have you consulted on that we
have consulted people and we're ongoing
with Consulting people but but obviously
I can't speak to the dog and um all we
can say is that he was running backward
and forwards and he was still in the
area where Nicholas possessions were and
that's all I can say more interested in
the gate and the path leading away from
that and the actual water at that time
when the witness found Willow was
between the bench and the gate however I
have to point out the dog could have got
out from there we'll take one more
question please everybody
the police and crime commission have
been kept apprised but the constabulary
has operational Independence and has
been carrying out the investigation and
information stays with the investigation
that's the nature of policing just given
given up I've said one more question and
I'll just give it to Nick to bring one
more in thank you thank you have an
elephant from the Sunday Times and
you've outlined what you've done so far
which is great and really helpful thank
you but are you able to talk us through
sort of what your plan might be where
the investigation will go in the coming
week or so and also what impact is this
having on Livestream police resources
and when do you think you may
um
you know you may look at scaling it down
and just one final point I know you said
you were going to elaborate on the
vulnerabilities but I've had three text
messages in the past five minutes asking
what they are and what that's about so
if we want to sort of dial down
speculation which might have made sense
for it to make that clear I'll take most
of that I think I think in terms of the
the scale of the investigation it is
continuing
um that will be kept under review but it
is it is at as much of a peak of
resourcing and intensity as it has been
both the search on the investigation
side will remain under review but we we
are a significant sized Force where
necessary withdrawn officers and
expertise and from across the force
our business as usual uh police and
communities of Lancashire has remained
unaffected by this we've sought support
nationally and we can draw on Mutual aid
from other police forces and regions if
we need to we'll keep it under review
Becky's experienced senior investigation
officer and we'll continue to to follow
the evidence the facts objectively as
any sio would do in terms of the
vulnerabilities
um I feel we've said as much as we can
about that it is personal private
information notice the investigation but
foremost in our our thoughts in addition
to the Integrity of the investigation is
the privacy of Nicholas family so we've
said as much as we can with that so
regressively I can't we can't take any
more questions thank you very much but I
do thank you for your attention today
thank you very much thank you
thanks man
helpful
because he's still alive
can we have a child at some point about
Friday I'm just going to do a live yeah